that's thank you I am super grateful
that there are that they're harder to
kiss there are just like this many
people who want to like be awake and
like at a talk at 9:00 in the morning
for me thank you I'll be talking about
time joint work with my cred student but
wrong saying who is not here
I noticed which is here for the a
semester but I think that she chose to
like hit sleep in is fine
I'm sure this she's seen this work
before and it's also joint work with um
her kraebel who is it um Richmond and to
folks who are like in my department yeah
Jame Andrade wah who just moved to
University of Texas so the change point
problem is one which it would you have
like a stream of um data and you want to
like identify some times at which
it which Nizam it did a change and like
a structural way and so at first we're
going to say the first K star points our
sample with from some pre change
distribution p0 and then a time k star
we're going to assume that things change
and some other host change the
distribution P P p1 and you don't know
the change point time K star and so
that's the the goal is to find is to
find this time K K star we're going to
assume p0 and p1 are both perfectly
known and that these points are being
sampled all right iid if you don't like
those assumptions wait until my very
last slide but until then these things
are going to hold what do we care maybe
we want to like out collect like I'm
Hospital data and see at what point are
we starting to see like dramatically
more cases of a like particular disease
and so the young CDC might want to be
doing this you also might have some like
I'm smart home devices who want to on
tests or you home or not is there like
activity in the home and for both of
these cases these are like highly
sensitive data and so we might care
about doing this privately I think for
this audience I'm gonna not really say
too much about the definition of like
I'm D P if you don't know it what have
you been at doing all week and so we're
going to use differential privacy and
the goal is we're going to want to
output some like a private estimate to
the change point time that is on a
friendship private with respect to
changing one single point in our data
stream
any questions
all right so here is an outline of both
the talk of the paper so we're first
going to talk about this offline case
how do we handle this
if you have like if you have like all of
your data known upfront and you want to
look back and say like at what time do I
think a change occurred in the past
tense who will then talk about the like
online case if you receive one single
data point at at a time
how can you quickly raise a flag what do
you think a like I'm change point
occurred and like in the paper we have
we have some sound like empirical
results but I figure for a theory crowd
I don't know if you guys care ok so
let's talk first about this offline case
so first before we talk about privacy
this is actually a very well had a
problem in d like a statistics case and
they use the like I'm cumulative sum
algorithm they came from back in the 50s
and it takes in some like input database
X and it's going to compute a log
likelihood ratio for each possible point
in time it's going to ask a time que how
likely do I think a change occurred at
this time
and so that's going to be our like log
of log likelihood and really it's going
to be
so really we're going to say I'm going
to sum over all time how likely it was
probability of seeing the data I've seen
X I under the like alternative
hypothesis
over the probability of them of I'm
seeing X I under the null but until time
K minus one this ratio was actually the
same because they both say they're gonna
be sampled from p0 for the first K minus
one times and so that's why it reduces
how the some actually starting at time K
and so that is our yeah question there's
no there's only we know that there's
only one change yeah it's just a matter
of how many changes for now yes we're
gonna talk about multiple change points
at the end but kind of been tail I tell
you otherwise something what's the null
hypothesis no change no yeah yeah and so
Helen all his things are sampled from p0
every time and the like alternative is
that they were sampled from p0 help
until K at which point things change to
being sampled from p1 so we assume that
and is like the time rise yeah yeah yeah
and because here we're still in the
offline case you see like the entire
data set up front
and so then and you like absence of um
privacy we just compute MLE
which is basically the time k at which
it was the most likely that a change
occurred you assume the change that
wouldn t happens once within the NZ yes
yes and that was the same question about
like multiple changes we will see that
at the very end but for most of the talk
is just watching and then you say that a
change occurred if we had played the
hood above sound like appropriately
chosen threshold based upon p 0 and P 1
and N and so that's how you handle
things if you don't care about privacy
and really we only touch the data
through this step and we either compute
the log likelihood probability or can we
take the like Arg max privately and at
least for now we're going to always
ignore this step and we're going to
always output some K that had the UM
highest log um likelihood in terms of
our private rhythm
and so and so I'm fortunately we do know
how to privately compute our maxes so
here's the like report noisy max
algorithm that was kind of folklore for
a long time until until the privacy book
and and it effectively calculates noisy
approximations for a stream of um
queries kind of tells you back with job
query how the largest noisy value and so
you takin queries and you like evaluate
queries and you add and you add Laplace
knows it's like um like parameter it
depends on your desired privacy
guarantee and on the other fence
integrity of F and you then just output
K hat that is a noisy art max
it's very simple and the nice thing is
that although you have possibly M
queries you don't have to pay in terms
of your pipes you budget for the fact
that M queries because really you just
care about one thing which is yum query
that has the dealer nom de part just I
just got you pencil it the idea for our
like offline private changepoint
algorithm is to run report news Emacs
these log likelihood ratios as our as
our um queries and so the algorithm goes
like this we have our like input
database and our privacy parameter and
we still compute the same like the same
likelihood ratios and then for each time
point we draw some some noise and this
step is actually not critical for the
algorithm but I put it here just to kind
of like illustrate a thing that you can
do if you don't care about privacy then
you can still compute this like non
private time le just based upon like
things you have done so far obviously if
you care about privacy don't actually
like output this but this is more just
kind of has like a highlight that you
can still recover the same like
non-private estimator if you want and
then are going to output an tilde which
is the like noisy arc max and so really
this is basically Q some pluses like
same
anybody see any problems with this look
at that then yes good good
so one caveat here is that we need this
to be finite and like hopefully small
and so and so really what is Delta L and
is this reasonable to assume
so it turns out Delta L is this thing
it's a difference between between this
like biggest ratio and the smallest
ratio within logs so it's nice that we
can compute this but really by assuming
this thing's I'm finite we're actually
like restricting ourselves to a class of
p0 and p1 and in particular it implies
sort of like a uniform bound on the
probability ratios of p0 and p1 and they
also have to have the same support so
it's fine if we have particular
distributions where this is like a
reasonable number
in fact this does not hold for example
for for p0 and p1 being like um
gaussians so this is certainly not the
most general case
hold off on until three slides and I'll
tell you how to remove this assumption
and for our accuracy guarantee we're
going to talk about alpha-beta accuracy
which is that we want to be within some
like additive alpha of the true change
point with high probability
okay so here's our main results so this
offline algorithm is first of all the
Frenchie private yay
and if we have this assumption then it's
alpha-beta accurate for this alpha and
I'll tell you how to interpret that in a
second and this C term is something like
the KL divergence between these two
these distributions it's not so metric
and so we have to take them in in both
directions but you can think of C is
being Jessie like um kale divergence
okay so how did you interpret this term
it's kind of weird and there's two
things it's like an important note is
that the like Emily estimate actually
has like this accuracy which is the same
as this first term up to some factors of
2 and so really this first term just
comes from the fact that we can't do
better than then they like non-private
estimate and it's actually worth I'm
saying that we are the first ones to
give even like non-private finite sample
accuracy guarantees it's like I'm Ellie
which is actually kind of shocking and I
thought that this was like for sure P
known and it turns out it's really
because like I'm how decisions and I'm
have you two scientists have different
things they mean when they say the word
accuracy on so on so we are the first
ones to give this this version of like
an accuracy guarantee
okay so this is effectively the best
that you can do even like non privately
and then there's like this term which
can be interpretive it's like saying
really the cost of privacy passim
tonically is roughly this kind of KL
divergence over epsilon because if you
compare these two terms so you have like
like i'm c over delta l squared here and
here you lose the square you also gain
gayness extra 1 over epsilon term and so
you're sort of trading off a c' for an
epsilon here and so effectively this is
saying this is the cost of doing this
probably privately is this term
and the proof idea kind of been like in
like one paragraph is saying really
believe it really there's like two
things that can possibly go wrong
I might have bad noise and I might have
bad data and by a bad noise some bad
data I really mean draws from the
underlying randomness that will cause me
to think that a change point was at some
time other than within this like alpha
window have it truly change right and so
if I have like well-behaved data and
they're gonna look pretty dramatically
different it's gonna be like you know p0
p1 and so we bound that by talking about
how far apart are these two
distributions and so that's why this
time KL divergence term is important
because it because it because it like
helps us bound how likely are we to have
samples that actually look very close
even though they're they're drawn from
like two different distributions and the
bad noise I might have like a great data
that are very well behaved like this and
like this and then maybe I just get like
wild noise drawers then make things look
like constant all the time well that's
pretty unlikely because I would have to
get like like like a bunch of noise
drawers
they're like outliers and don't really
look like they're being sampled from
this cycle pause and so we found that
error using something like a
concentration inequality is on these
drawers
okay and so I promised you how I can
handle things if if this is not bounded
effectively effectively we can run the
same algorithm it were just going to
like truncates or log-likelihood and so
before we had this sum that we're now
just going to like truncate it using
some like a smartly chosen parameter a
we're going to con truncate it to be
within some range and the nice thing is
that now the Delta L is just a because
they have ensured it and it's actually
not so different than if you're doing
private deep learning and you want to
clip gradients and kind of like in the
worst case they can be very very large
but it actually helps you doing it
privately to do that to do that um
pupping okay guys just it just can't
your money are you adding noise to hell
or you are adding noise to each summit
we're adding noise to each L okay yeah
yeah the variance isn't really constant
as a function of carry so is it
practically makes instant
um that is to say one occasion and
there's one term when K is one there's
in terms yeah that's a good question
that I'll have to think about more about
like how the variance looks as because
this is like a this is a problem they
run into a lot in changepoint right is
that you've normalized things because
the variances are always different in
some way yeah it was actually shocking
as we expected
this clipping to really harm accuracy
because effectively you're like I'm
throwing away information and that might
be very important but it didn't at all
and in fact we found that in like a lot
of cases you actually want this A to B
it's like very very small because him
like a lot of cases knowing even just
like I'm the sign of this has like
enough information is it positive or is
it negative and so that was like pretty
surprising and so kind of be like a
miracle of this says if you run the same
algorithm and you just plug in Delta L a
instead of L they're like on the same
algorithm works and you actually get the
same privacy guarantee and the same
accuracy and you just swap out Delta L
with a and this was in fact like very
surprising to all to us
it may be like related to that
any questions on this can you think in
who you measure accuracy yeah um so this
is for this's pusses is the probability
of 1 minus beta I'm going to be at most
an additive of alpha away from the true
change of plans
and so here if you do this like I'm funk
Asia and like the exact same thing will
work he does some swap out a here and
here and the same bound holds and also
holds here to the Bucky's would just so
there's a true change point time k k
star and we're going to produce some
like a private estimate K tilde and we
want the like on absolute value
difference between K between K tilde and
K star to be at most alpha with
probability 1 minus beta so what about
if there's no change why this is because
this is usually the first question right
is there change points there's above
some threshold and then if it is
where's yeah so so so here we assume in
the offline case we assume that there is
a change point and this will make more
sense as we move into the online setting
where you're first going to like on test
if there is one and then if there is one
then you'll call this one is a pepper
teen I'm even in the offline case the
perfect it still it makes sense to ask
is there a change yeah
so yeah but it's still it you still are
going to do it privately insects right
yes let's just just to interpret the
accuracy guarantee so whenever are very
smaller than one so this is saying that
the probability of correctly correctly
detecting the ten-point it's 1 minus
thing because because you're talking
about index right so yeah this alpha
shouldn't be smaller than what I mean
you could if C is okay okay yeah yes so
I want to also compare this to a paper
that I'm him at about the same time and
we have a few heavy like authors here
I'm trying to like map first names and
last names Clemmie Gao tamadra
high-demand John and this was and like
otters talk on Monday and so if you were
here then you saw this talk if not just
recorded it's a great paper and so this
was done around the same time and came
out probably like a couple months after
ours and so they also solve saw the same
problem
private um private John went but they do
this using algorithms at the developed
or like on for like um private
hypothesis testing and they effectively
have like a reduction between these two
problems saying that you can use these
algorithms to solve this problem and you
mean like really high like a high level
both algorithms both algorithms are like
I'm effectively doing the same thing
they both modified the truth
distributions in some ways and the
accuracy depends on some distance
measure between these like modified
distributions we have different
modification tools and we use different
like on distance measures but kind of
like a bird's eye view like effectively
doing the same thing but because of
these
but feel like I'm because of these
differences you can't really compare
accuracy across one or the other without
knowing like I'm specifics of the exact
distributions and Penny will say it make
an overly stylized model that is really
not fair to kind of like either paper
ours is better in the case of a large
change but theirs is better like I'm
finding small changes but again I want
to like emphasize this is like a this is
like an overly stylized model and it's
not like a blanket statement and you
really have to kind of like look at if
you like exact accuracy balance on the
particular distributions to make it an
exact comparison they're kind of like in
the same thing
and more questions about the offline
stuff yeah so do I do you know it does
it change yeah but both papers assume
that p1 is or whatever the alternative
is is some fixed probably like fixed
model because no usually with the change
point you if there is a change you have
to still estimate the models so ours
does I don't know
we also have a model where it starts off
as a fixed distribution and then changes
to something which is harder but we with
the caveat that it has to be same
discrete distribution and you know the
size it's kind of a reduction from my
goodness of fit testing to change point
detection of that later times you can
probably do this birth given a sort of
goodness of fit style algorithm you can
plug it into our reduction and we'll
still give you something okay that make
sense does the typical change point is
that there's a change but I don't know
the underlying models right so they
still have to be fit so usually there's
it's ratios of like maximum likelihood
estimators of music I mean hold off
until my very last slide okay okay well
uh discuss
all right so if it's online case so this
is a strictly harder because you have to
find the change quickly without very
much post change data right because if
you like wait a long time and you're
like I'm gonna collect more and more
data then are going to be too late then
the change will have like happened a
long time and so the approach is going
to be to first privately like I'm check
if a change occurred and then once we
have a change then we're going to run or
like offline off with them on that paper
we're going to check by by looking like
a sliding window of size N and I'm going
to ask do I think a change occurred in
this window have the last endpoints
fortunately we like also have a like
private algorithm for this and so again
thank you to the privacy community for
making great great tools in the past
decade this algorithm is the like above
noisy threshold algorithm which is
effectively what lives beneath sparse
vector and so and so this is a like a
private algorithm for like I'm finding
which queries in a stream have an answer
above a given threshold and it works
like this and so takes in some like
input database and a stream of um
queries and has to be bounds price
parameter and some threshold T we're
gonna first noise up or like threshold
and then for each query we're going to
sample
applause noise again and we're going to
check if a noisy answer to that query on
the data is above like a noisy version
of the threshold then I'm going to say
it was time I and if and halt and if not
they were gonna say at time I I saw I
saw no change and then we'll I'm
continue in this loop and so effectively
just tells you but it's a first time and
which see like a noisy answer of his
query was above and a like noisy
aberration of our threshold
okay so actually here's how we're going
to run our first step is we're going to
run above noisy threshold on these
partial log likelihood queries in a I'm
sliding window have size N and so this
is our like on line algorithm which is
basically doing these two things so we
take in database privacy parameter
threshold noise up our threshold and for
each data point I'm going to compute LJ
which is the maximum of the log
likelihood ratio of the last endpoints
and so really this is saying how likely
is it that I think a change occurred and
the less endpoints over then going to
like add noise and check is the noisy
answer to just query is above are on the
threshold and if yes they were going to
run offline algorithm on these last
endpoints and if they were done then and
if not they were gonna keep keep like
going back and we'll just some continue
this loop until you find some point to
which we think a change
we'll kill them ha and is a parameter
that you can can choose alternatively
think of it as the size of the data that
you start with on the first day and so
if you have some past database and then
like I'm tomorrow then you'll get one
new point and and then you can slide one
and so it's either your choice or so
constraint based upon how much data you
have a day one
all right and so here's the main result
in the and the online case and so it's
epsilon differentially private again
we're in this case where we're going to
assume Delta L is like founded and you
have some smartly chosen threshold then
it's alpha beta accurate for this alpha
and a few things to say before we like
interpret this thing so so RC parameter
is the same KL divergence how do we
choose these um thresholds in the paper
we have like on exact expressions of
these they are really big and really
ugly and so if you think this is a bad
expression wait until you see our T's
but effectively this is a constant and
this is something like order n and so
you like shouldn't be concerned about
this being like an empty set okay and so
back
order n and as a size at the bureau
window
what is T in your question t is our
threshold not your stream size yeah yeah
and so in fact your stream can be
infinite as long as your change point
time is it sound like finite time point
yeah okay and so this actually looks
extremely similar to what we had before
and so this is so this is great news
we have only lost some factors of 2
compared to the online or like I'm
compared to the offline case and so
really this one says do in fact don't
lose anything aside from some constants
from being and it's like much harder
environment and of course this can also
be done without without this like
assumption we just used offline non
truncated as the thing that we call once
we have found an window you can do the
same thing and just call this like on
truncated version and it will like and
it will like them qualitatively be the
same we haven't done the math maybe you
lose an extra like factor of 2 or
something but but it will be effectively
the same thing and I think like an
important thing to note in both of these
both in the like online and then the
offline case is that there is like no
dependence on N and this is less
surprising in the online case because
this n is like some is just some kind of
like internal parameter but it's more
surprising in the offline case because
it's saying that your accuracy is going
to be constant no matter how much data
you either do or don't have
so I'll give a few more like on
hand-wavy proof ideas and so for like um
probably BC it's actually a very
straightforward we give like half our
privacy budget to the above noisy
threshold and we give half our are like
privacy budget house it's like offline
help algorithm and we don't compose to
get overall epsilon and this is where
our sort of like factors of two arrive
is because we are losing them in this
case because we obviously and we're
accuracy it's a little bit more detailed
so we have two things that can go go
wrong we might fail to pick the right
window and we might also fail within the
correct window after we have Amin
joeszmidt and so we have beta over to
failure probability for this like um
window choice and again there's kind of
like two things that can go wrong here
you might raise the alarm too early
we might that we might pick a window
before a like I'm change point occurred
and so that's the role of this TL is
making sure that our threshold is going
to be high high enough to have a low
false positive rate because we have to
have have some value above TL and so we
have to have sufficient likelihood of a
change occurring and so we we bound it
with this term how we also can't fail to
raise an alarm at the true change and
the adult wants like on passive change
points because then I will have like I'm
miss it and so that's the role of this
um it's t8 which is making sure your
threshold isn't so high you might fail
to raise an alarm even with like a true
change occurred and so these two things
entered with high probability we're
going to find the correct window
and then we have this like data over to
failure probability for being for being
more than alpha far conditioned on
finding the right window is this is like
I would answer this is like I'm
conditioned on not being in this bad
event I now have to find the correct
change change point within that within
that window fortunately we already have
like an accuracy theorem that ensures
those high probability we're going to be
in the right window and then we just
take Union bounds over these two things
and so here there's a couple more
factors of two and so there's where
we're like all of our missing twos came
any questions on my very hand wavy roof
ideas I like even call them ideas
because they like it isn't even like a
real sketch yet it's just like a big
it's like a cloud dream have a proof
okay and so if I'm going to asked about
multiple change points a few people did
I think actually this is kind of like a
nice kind of like meta point which is it
in like on the statistics this is a
really hard problem but at the same time
and like I'm privacy
Harley comes far sector can be like I'm
very easily extended to find multiple
above threshold queries and so I told my
like on statistics co-authors I think
that we can like do this it's really
straightforward and they're like and
they're like no no no and that's way too
hard it's definitely going to be like
its own paper and like I don't think so
and like in fact because of our sector
it really is just the same as running em
sequential instantiation of the some
single change point and so you feel like
this is kind of like a kind of like a
meta almost like a almost like a
proselytizing what it's like working
across fields is that really it's not
like we did magic here in the math but
rather we saw there's is like very
powerful privacy tools and they can be
used to solve a problem that is hard
without these privacy tools and so we
applied its and in fact it was like I
don't want to say that it was like super
straightforward because of course there
was a bunch of like math details but
really we just noticed we have tools to
solve an existing hard problem and let's
do that
assume that there are two different
levels and jumping from here to there
are different times within the end
sequence so here we're going to find M
change points and they can be points
being drawn because they brought like
I'm from like I'm M plus 1 different
distributions and so don't think of it
as things being drawn from like a level
but think of it as has like a points
being drawn from these different
distributions but then your L definition
of L does it change hang on one side
yeah okay and so first I'll tell you
what I mean theorem is and it really
looks exactly the same we just have some
like additional factors of M and our
inner log and so really date and so
really I D like I'm only change in our
loss is just this log M and this
comments from doing a like a Union bound
over these em like a sequential change
point in two problems some and some like
important details because I don't want
to say that it was just kind of like an
immediate application the fact there was
a lot of math under the hood so we have
to reset every time oh oh or like I'm
thresholds and our Delta L because we're
having different time distributions
every time and so you have to reset
these like you would for a single change
point between time I and time I plus 1
and we also can't have these change
points being too close they have to be
at most n apart and this kind of makes
sense intuitively right right because if
I have to fuse samples from one
distribution that might just look like a
few outliers being sampled from like a
previous distribution it's like
intuitively it makes sense that we need
some bound on these being like I'm
sufficiently far apart it turns out to
also
need this algorithmically because we're
going to wait n endpoints after we have
like identified a like I'm change point
to estimate before we restart the Z like
um however them and so in this picture
imagine this is like um imagine this is
like time here and say there's sound
like a true change point K star I and so
things before this are sampled from one
distribution and things after this are
being sampled from like a different
distribution and we found some window
here have size N and we called off line
change point to the output K tilde I
here had we found this and so then we're
going to wait until we have accumulated
had more points before we're going to
start our next window here why do we do
this for two reasons first because we
don't want to reuse data from the
previous window if we started just right
here then kind of like these points are
going to be used in both windows and
then we have some kind of like
complicated conditioning happening and
we can no longer claim these points are
actually sampled iid but rather they are
sampled from the distribution that would
cause us to identify this has a change
point and that's complicated to sort of
like reason about so we don't want to
use these twice additionally we don't
want like accidentally accidentally use
data from the wrong distribution because
again if I started my new window here
then it would have some points here that
are not actually drawn from P I but
they're actually drawn from P I minus
one and so that will kind of like throw
off our math and so we wait
and poins and then we start to new
I'll just say kind of like one thing
about the empirical results in the paper
so we first fat find in fact in fact
that are like um that are like I'm
theoretical results up here up here with
empirically as well
and we also ran some like a relations in
the case where we had the wrong belief
about how the data points are drawn and
so we had the wrong p0 the wrong p1 and
the algorithm still seemed to find
approximately the right change point and
so that tells us we should try to do
theory about but the case in which we
don't know these exact distributions
which we are currently doing and so this
is Joe I said this is so this is joy to
work like my two grad students Yulia and
pointer on
and so without para kraebel and we
started out trying to relax the
Assumption have kind of like have kind
of like one dramatic change point how we
actually thought about like I'm drift
and so maybe points aren't really being
sampled iid but maybe there's sound like
a smoothly changing the distribution we
should be able to like identify and to
measure that change as well and then it
turned out kind of a surprisingly at
these same techniques also work in the
case we don't exactly know the they like
I'm pre change in the post change
distributions if it was kind of
surprising to us but the math ends up
being the the same so that's great and
they will say that kind of like a larger
goal is thinking about like online
learning algorithms they can somehow
self-audit for like um
correctness and so maybe I have first
learned some like I'm a classifier on
some old data and I acquire new data and
I want to at some point say my new data
look pretty different from the old stuff
I think I need to retrain my like how
pacifier and like in this past new rips
with like I was terrible and with two
other grad students that like um Georgia
Tech we did this for kind of like worst
case adversarial data grows but of
course if you think their data are not
going to change very often then you can
probably do a whole lot better in this
like I'm change planes environment thank
you so I guess we we had a few questions
during the talk so maybe since we're
running a little late
maybe Poole will hold further questions
until the break